back now the spy fillers of fiction in
the movies paint a life of adventure
fast cars and gorgeous women but the
reality is much different and tonight
we're getting a close-up look at former
fbi agent robert hanson now in prison
for life after being caught spying for
russia
and we're joined now by liz wheel who
wrote the fantastic book a spy in plain
sight the story of robert henson lise
thanks so much for being here you write
in your book that within a year of
taking his position at the fbi in new
york
hanson was already facing money problems
and therefore decided to become a spy
jack hoeshower his best friend
will tell you that you know from very
early on he had this fixation really
with james bond everything glamour about
james bond you know rescuing the damsel
in distress
being having this glamorous spy
lifestyle
elegance palaces and beautiful women
oh beginning with the very first james
bond movie he and i always went to
uh opening of the latest james bond
movie together and what about james bond
what was the fascination what did he
like about that oh well
what do young guys like about beautiful
women in fast cars i mean that's
uh
andy and the adventure
whereas hanson himself in person was
nothing like that he was kind of a nerd
you know computer guy but he wanted that
so there was that he was also when he
joined the fbi
he would become what i would call brian
a disgruntled employee he felt like he
was always the smartest guy in the room
and the other agents around him didn't
appreciate that didn't you know flower
him with praise and everything
so he was disgruntled
he wanted glamour he needed money and
the and the soviets the russians
flowery letters you know familial
response to him they gave him that
adoration that he was seeking how much
damage did robert hansen do
a lot i mean the uh the justice
department has put the actual dollar
value of of hanson's damage at 10
billion 10 billion
but i don't know brian that you can put
a dollar value on the fact that he cost
people's lives i mean one of his first
communique
with his russian handler churchian
was the identity of a guy um in russia
that we had a russian asset who was
doing really good work for us a guy
named polyakov he gives over that
information the russians grab up paul
you calf polikov execute him in the most
heinous of ways and videotape that
execution so how do you put a dollar
value on that you know all these lives
that were lost i don't think you can
why did it take so long to figure out
who the mole was to find robert hansen
you know the fbi uh didn't want to look
internally they didn't really police
themselves at some point they realized
that they had a mole there was a mole
somewhere within the fbi or the cia
simply because they've lost all their
russian assets they were all dead you
know because their identities had been
revealed by hanson
but when they started looking they could
make this matrix what they call a matrix
and there were people in this room they
called the vault room putting this
matrix together and hanson was never in
it no fbi agent was it was a cia guy
named brian kelly they first targeted
outed him he had done nothing wrong
ruined his life i spoke with his widow
about it
and it was all because they didn't
really think that somebody inside the
agency could be so horrid and so
treacherous that's what took so long
where is robert hansen today
he is thankful he is locked up in a
super max in florence colorado he's got
23-hour day solitary confinement and in
the hour that he's off he could go hang
out with people like the unabomber
el chapo
you know that sort of fun crowd
is he at all contrite
you know his psychiatrist dr charney
said he was a little bit
he was more worried about bonnie and
that she didn't want her to be
prosecuted uh i don't think he's ever
really apologized i don't think with a
guy like hanson you ever really know
what he's thinking because again he's
able to compartmentalize right he can
say i'm sorry
and then on the other side be going but
i really did the right thing so i don't
believe a word this guy says
any sense of guilt for the lives he cost
no
unbelievable you know and again the
persona that he had was devout catholic
opus dei even went to mass every day
um called the russians godless people
commies he was in the you know top level
of our counter-espionage unit in the fbi
so his outward appearance and and
everything was completely the opposite
of who he actually was for all those 20
years
all right please real thank you so much
for being here with us a fascinating
book a spy in plain sight
thanks brian
up next this week's winners and losers
in the media bombshell testimony in
washington
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined now
by aidan mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media group and this
week one big winner only the media
rollout campaign of that january 6
select committee in the house of
representatives with bombshell testimony
this week from a former white house aide
cassidy hutchinson
i'm the effing president
take me up to the capitol now
to which bobby responded sir
we have to go back to the west wing
the president
reached up towards the front of the
vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
mr engel grabbed his arm
said sir you need to take your hand off
the steering wheel
we're going back to the west wing we're
not going to the capitol
mr trump then used his free hand to
lunge towards bobby angle and mr when mr
ronaldo had recounted this story to me
he had motioned towards his clavicles
aiden one of a number of bombshell
revelations from the former white house
aide the committee decided to have this
special hearing that they had not
previously scheduled and was it a big
bombshell as expected uh it most
certainly was i think this was
definitely the biggest bombshell hearing
that we've had thus far in all of the
january 6 committee hearings we were
expecting to have two weeks off brian uh
from these hearings uh which so far have
uh provided a number of revelations
about uh trump's behavior uh and what
was happening in the inside the white
house during january 6th
this one provided the m the closest
account of what actually happened uh
within trump's inner circle um we have
witness testimony for there was one sole
witness in the snap hearing that was
cassidy hutchinson who you just saw
there
she is an aide to mark meadows who at
the time was president donald trump's
chief of staff
those revelations included the fact that
trump apparently was told
that his supporters were armed
police had a number of reports that
supporters were carrying ar-15s handguns
bear mace uh as well as body armor and
that trump actually wanted them to be
still allowed to come into his rally and
that he actually told
the secret service to let them in
because they weren't going to hurt trump
um obviously the implication there is
that they were going to hurt other
people or that they wanted to hurt other
people
that was just one of the shocking
revelations that she disclosed in this
hearing another that you just heard in
that video was that trump actually
wanted to go to the capitol with his
supporters and lunged at a secret
service agent tried to grab the steering
wheel of a secret service suv to get
them to take him to the capitol i can
only imagine what that would have been
like if trump actually had gone to the
capitol where his supporters were
storming uh it and uh calling to hang
mike pence as vice president so as a
media strategy this has worked very well
i think it's been a phenomenal hearings
just in terms of the media strategy and
i think you can put a lot of that credit
up to liz cheney uh the representative
who is a chairman of this committee the
pacing has been incredible and the
revelations have been truly shocking
throughout all right aid mclaughlin
thank you so much for being with us here
tonight for this week's winners and
losers in the media that's our program
for tonight thanks for joining us we'll
see you back here again next week on the
law and crime trial network
you